so when does someone call a corner and
and what is a corner death investigator
I'm going to call it a corner for the
episode that's fine okay what is a
corner so a coroner is
um an elected position
but
what we do is we go out when someone
dies or we're called every time someone
dies that lives within our Parish okay
our County or county in Louisiana it's
parishes
um so we will we're called if it's a
natural case or if it's a homicide
suicide of any of the manners of death
anytime it's an accident or just your
general natural death it comes to us
okay we have to pick up the phone and
decide you know is this natural causes
or is there Foul Play we work closely
with police okay so the police give you
a call that's right yes so take me
through like an interesting call that's
coming in you know especially down here
in Louisiana dang yeah you know I knew
people that could you know they couldn't
learn the alphabet and they took their
own life that's right we see a lot of
that you know there's a lot of
preventable deaths that we can talk
about but you know a typical call in
Louisiana is
um anything from heart disease suicide
OD
um but to be more specific
um
we've had many that they find a body
floating in the bayou and that can be
different you know because they've been
exposed to water so you know they may be
bloated more some of the the surface
evidence or the trace evidence that we
use is not there because they've been
floating you can see where Turtles and
and other animals in the water have
nipped at them oh yeah so it can be
somewhat gruesome and then hard to tell
you know why are they in this water you
know they're dressed in regular street
clothes they weren't you know they
weren't swimming they weren't swimming
they weren't fishing and they're in the
water
um sometimes people OD and their friends
have no clue what to do with them so
they throw them into the Bayou
um sometimes these guys are just you
know hanging out and they slip and fall
and hit their head or they pass out you
know we don't always know what got them
to the Bayou now how do those bodies
look if you roll up on a bot because
I've always wanted to find a deceased
body I think a lot of people have bucket
list of mine I see them every day but
I've never rolled up on one yeah yeah
yeah
um is why is that a bucket list thing
for people I don't know but it happens
often I had a guy cutting the grass at a
rent house and found a body God did he
get any Intel or he just got lucky no he
just got lucky he was cutting grass and
boom he found that body a lot of times
if you work and stay focused and you
keep working towards I mean you know
it's better than some lazy dude who's
doing nothing finding a body right at
least that guy's out there and doing
something well when that lazy person
finds about it you got a question how
did you find this body you know yeah
um we had a good point we had one
recently that was just a driver was
passing by and there was a lady in the
ditch now what was interesting was her
arms were removed she was a Mexican
female
so they removed her arms because of her
tattoos so this was a Oh the killer this
was a hit job correct and they didn't
want her identified you know so they see
this in a ditch and they call us and
then we got to figure out where's the
arms you know so
um there's interesting cases like that
where people just you know they right
time right place and they find bodies
and so he says did you roll up on that
scene with no arms yes yes so when you
get there what's going on like are
people Milling around is somebody
if you know like what's the scene like
when you roll up on it well in that
regard there's no family's present you
know
um it's different than most you know
it's a lot of sheriffs uh standing
around looking at the dead body now we
have jurisdiction on that body and
legally they're not supposed to touch
that body until we get there okay so of
course I would get there look at the
scene you know to try to find out does
she have family around here what's she
doing in this area she's not from here
um they'll do an investigation the law
enforcement will do an investigation on
the airport and then I'll start looking
at the body for obvious signs of Foul
Play and in this regard she had no arms
so we knew something wasn't right and it
wasn't like an alligator or an animal
came out and removed her arms this was
intentional wow you know so in that case
we would get them to an autopsy oh yeah
yeah I mean I had a guy find a foot once
it was from a from a fatality but they
called me and this was you know Weeks
Later hey we found a foot would you come
pick it up they don't want to touch it
even you know so I throw a bag in my car
and I go grab a foot it's it's it's a
different lifestyle you know yeah you
know if I get pulled over yeah you know
carrying anything uh yeah man I got a
foot in my car yeah bruh I got a 10 and
a half in the trunk absolutely
absolutely dude that's wild man yeah
that's interesting and you put that foot
in the trunk you put it in the back seat
what do you do yeah well in that case I
figured it would be pretty pretty gnarly
so I actually brought a disposable ice
chest and packed it in there and then
got it to the funeral home that uh they
brought her body to
um she may have been sent to Cremation
but uh either way the funeral home would
take care of that body part okay enough
traveled was with worse so you know in
Louisiana it doesn't snow often
yeah they had a we had a case years ago
where it was an infant death and the
autopsy places in um
the autopsy place is about an hour and a
half away from our where we live okay or
where we work in our Parish so um they
had a baby that had passed away and they
asked hey it was snowing really bad hey
can you meet us halfway with this child
and I'm in my personal car I'm like sure
so the baby of course is in a body bag
yeah
um so I'm driving down the highway with
a with a baby and how big is that body
but I mean it's like a gallon or
something well it's you know it's like a
duffel bag or a baby oh yeah but you
know again you get pulled over and I
have an unmarked car I'm in street
clothes or normally scrubs oh you know
what are you carrying at least you're
not in a Miata or something yeah yeah
you get pulled over in a Miata and you
got a baby in a duffel bag bro I kind of
I kind of went over the speed limit just
to kind of maybe maybe man if I could
only get pulled over here you know uh it
would be an interesting case but no you
know it's sad for when we lose babies
like that but the fact of the matter is
the baby needed to go to autopsy and
we'll do anything we can to to assist in
that regard and if it meant driving
through the snow 30 45 minutes you know
we'll do that yeah that's uh some of the
things that we do to help so I was
called to one case where the deputies
said um
this one's
um this case is unusual we'd like you to
come out and so then I go out and they
had noticed some blood dripping on the
floor on the floor blood stains out of
the body just in no just on the floor
okay that's all they've noticed right
they saw that and then the body was an
adult male on a couch okay
um so I walked into the house and I mean
we're we're reading everything the
minute we get on scene even even you
know what friends and family are there
how do they look who's their neighbors
uh what area they live in so I walk into
the house and this was kind of in the
country and uh the first thing I see is
he had Mickey's Malt Liquor memorabilia
everywhere so I said okay okay I like
this guy's style you know he's a
middle-aged guy yeah he's a Kappa Sig
probably yeah so I'm looking at that and
then I asked the detectives to show me
the the where the the blood stains are
well I go and I look and there were some
cobwebs over the door so I could tell
that that home hadn't that that area of
the house hadn't been used okay just
from the cobwebs and stuff okay but when
I opened the fridge there was a intact
Hawks head in the fridge with fur on it
I mean that's odd you know and yeah and
then so then I look in the oven and the
guy's making cracklins in an oven now if
you've ever made cracklins you know
you're stirring those in grease when
you're baking cracklins on a Tuesday
night and you save the hog's head to
make Hog's head cheese later you're
going to definitely have heart disease
you know there's no foul play here
fellas and that blood probably came when
he was moving the hog's head from the
kitchen to the I mean from the counter
to the refrigerator oh from the actual
hog you think yeah yeah absolutely so
you know again when you're on your last
limb for a snack man I'm talking about
yeah that's crazy when you bake in
cracklins bro you're gonna have high
cholesterol at a minimum
um but you know again the blood stains
triggered the law enforcement to to call
and uh the fridge told me the story yeah
as well as the way the guy lived he
smoked cigarettes he had you know
alcohol everywhere
um and Papa Was a Rolling Stone you know
he he that environment told me you know
that what was going on with him right it
gave you a lot of Clues right there now
say if you pull up on like let's go back
to that water body right right what
happens to a body when it's in water
because I think suddenly a lot of people
fantasize that's one of the fantasies
I'm gonna find a body you know it's
either in the Woods by the interstate or
I'm going to walk down by a creek bank
and there's going to be a body right
there I think that's some of the general
fantasy of humans
um what is that body realistically look
like depending on how long it's been in
yeah so you know
it bloats you get a lot of bloating in
the water the whole body puffs up uh
normally the tongue protrudes out uh you
don't think about that the gases and the
the gases and the decomposure you know
the body sink and then they rise when
when the gases start to to fill up the
body and that's when we find them a lot
of times they'll be snagged in a in
branches on a bayou or in the river
um but that body's gonna bloat a lot and
then again Turtles and other animals out
in the water will start pecking at them
so it looks a little bit more traumatic
than it is
um but if we're unsure we can always
send that body to autopsy to try to
determine exactly what happened and
they'll take them apart and a lot of
times they'll cut into their heart and
realize well this guy had a massive
heart attack I see you know so there was
no foul play or he's full of drugs and
there's no external trauma so nobody hit
him in the back of the head and threw
him in there
um
yeah maybe pull up a little water bloat
for us
oh
yeah so that's you know
online these days it looks like a
Simpsons character huh he does
sorry to say that I feel that it's a
human being
um oh my gosh so we go from looking
pretty healthy to not healthy pretty how
pretty quickly I mean that's
unbelievable yeah and you know
especially in Louisiana it's so hot and
so humid and you'd just be amazed at
people that live with no electricity oh
bruh if you leave a baby in the yard for
30 minutes but I'd have algae on one
side yeah yeah I mean it you know it's
um
it's just like that nature really Reigns
Supreme down there it really does
um and then some people are just really
hardcore on drugs you know we had a
house one time that in the kitchen there
was a piece of plywood and when the
officer slid the plywood back that's
where they were using the restroom they
were in a hole in the kitchen
and then they would cover it up with a
piece of wood I mean that's that that's
pretty hardcore in your home but you'll
see the enemies too really you'll see
that you know with people that just
abuse drugs to the point of you know
they're living in condemned homes or but
I got called one time and the guy was
still alive they were doing CPR and he
had a heartbeat so I walked as I'm
walking up to the house I see the
families I see their posture change like
you know oh the corners here it's
not good and you know so I walk in and
the paramedic says we got a heart rate
and I'm like he's not dead yet
who called me so I immediately walk out
and I wave at the family and that guy's
still alive today and you can imagine
them saying you was so sick wow the
coroner came you know
um those are you know we see crazy
things uh one lady was told to put jelly
she had a really bad infection she was
putting jelly uh between her legs okay
somebody said put some jelly on it well
she was right what you mean like uh
Smuckers or something well that's what
she was using Okay normally it would be
more of a K-Y Jelly or something for
that and they her legs were purple and
it was like what what's going on here
and her her neighbor said you know well
she was putting jelly on it and it's
like wait what you were using the smoker
that's the wrong kind of jelly but you
know we've seen wedding rings around
penises it's like man how'd you even get
that on there yeah just wow that must
have been that's a big promise yeah yeah
huge
um you know we see bizarre things like
that that people do auto-erotic deaths
or actually very dangerous we we
actually get a not a lot but enough of
them and that's where people are
pleasuring themselves and also hang
themselves yeah they they're starving
their body of oxygen you know okay doing
that you need a spotter because it's so
common for people to die yeah when
they're doing that so uh well if
you got a spotter you don't even need to
do it usually well it depends but yeah I
guess yeah people's into different stuff
and people are autistic people you know
bad things can happen in that regard
um
just bizarre bizarre things now uh back
to the we were talking about animals I
had a call from police and they weren't
sure they didn't see a gun but it
appeared that someone had there was Foul
Play based on the the face and of the
decedent okay and that was just rodents
you know that had gotten yeah so it
looked you know suspicious of a homicide
you know so I don't know if rats get in
there that's right so we can get out
there and say no no this is you know
we'll we'll still send an autopsy to be
sure in some in some cases but don't
make a cheese out of anything huh that's
right post-mortadella that's right
that's right other crazy cases or uh
anal insertions it's like what people
and what are people doing it for for
pleasure oh okay you know we would see
that a lot in the Eeyore but I had a
case where the guy obviously didn't want
to go to the ER and so he had had a
hammer and was using the backside of a
hammer to put in his buttocks right
right and that can perforate your colon
and then you get really septic yeah so
you know things like that
um
another interesting case would be um
huffing where people use keyboard
cleaner to get high and those deaths
occur in parking lots of stores
most frequently you're going to find a
Huffer in the parking lot at Walmart oh
because they get out yeah and and
so I had one guy actually a veteran and
that's how he would stop his nightmares
it was the only thing that worked and so
law enforcement's on scene and they're
like we can't find any drugs but there's
air cans everywhere you know and that's
dangerous the worst is when you think
you're doing like huffing like one of
those things and you accidentally get
one of those horns yeah I can imagine
that's a wake-up call
that's the Lord trying to say Hey look
it's time to stop yeah I'm a rescue you
real quick daddy you know that's the
worst man you ever found somebody hiding
somewhere real neat like or somebody
died during hide and go seek or
something uh yeah well you know there
was a guy under a house once you know
and uh you know no clothes on
I wouldn't like that part yeah naked
under a house
eating popsicles oh yeah yeah I mean
that you know that's uh that's different
yeah yeah that's a different way to do
it PCP you know so yeah makes you makes
you a bit crazy uh
but you know truck drivers we get truck
driver deaths a lot they're from out of
state why why do you get truck driver
deaths a lot well not a lot but we get
them we have truck stops and a lot of
times they'll pull over and look truck
drivers aren't healthy I mean they're
big guys because they drive all day long
and uh you know sometimes I'll I'll get
called out and I'll be in somebody's
truck I've never been in a truck
driver's truck before until I started
doing this and I'm looking at how they
live and
um
you know they notify their parents by
their family by phone and so the you
know maybe the wife's flying in to get
his personal belongings and the truck's
full of condoms and it's like oh man I
don't want this wife coming into his
truck so you know hey can we throw this
stuff out you know before the life gets
there yeah give them up give him a
little bit I don't want the Family's
last thoughts to yeah you know so there
are there are uh different cases in
different positions that we're in for
sure
um it's it's just it's an interesting
job and you know um I'm very sympathetic
and compassionate when I'm you know we
we all get faster as we work we get
faster at things we do you know we learn
how to do them faster and
um every once in a while I have to stop
and remind myself to slow down and to
make eye contact with that family and
and to be really compassionate you know
yeah
um yeah that's the nature of everything
I think once you get in the flow of
something too much you know yeah you do
it too fast yeah and you don't stop to
you know maybe spend that extra time
with them to reassure them that you know
that their family's taken care of so
yeah